testing disaster recovery and migrating
workloads between sites are the primary
advantages of site recovery manager on
google cloud vmware engine
i'm darren schmitz with vmware and in
this final video of the series we will
configure and test a recovery plan
migrate the example application to the
other site and perform a reprotect
in the previous video the replications
had just finished transferring the data
and have transitioned to a green okay
status
as discussed previously the protection
group auto created with our replications
contains our three example virtual
machines for app one
and we can also switch to the recovery
plan to customize it
one of the helpful features of the
recovery plan is the ability to suspend
non-critical vms at the recovery site
a common example of this is where a site
is used for development and the virtual
machines can be suspended to free
resources for the production workloads
when testing the plan test networks will
be created to isolate the workloads and
prevent ip address conflicts
this also gives administrators an
opportunity to non-disruptively test
upgrades or patches on the workload
while the test copies of the vms are
running
finally the recovery plan has five
priority groups that vms can be placed
into for a prescribed startup order
for example if ubuntu serve001 is a
database dns or active directory server
that needs to start prior to the others
it can be assigned into priority group
2.
before we start the test let's examine
what each site looks like before and
after
the primary site has three application
servers running while the secondary site
has the placeholder vms
placeholder vms indicate those vms are
being protected at the primary site
initiating the test opens a wizard
asking whether replicating recent
changes to the recovery site is desired
unchecking this box presents the
opportunity to simulate a failure where
the primary site is unreachable
as the test starts it will proceed
through each of the recovery steps to
simulate what it will do when the plan
is run
it will synchronize and configure the
storage create the test networks and
start powering on the virtual machines
in a few moments an admin can inspect
and test the application to verify the
plan completed as expected
flipping over to the secondary site the
placeholder vms have been started and
added to the isolated test network
switching to the primary site the
application is still running
uninterrupted
as a feature for the recovery plan a
history is recorded to examine the
carried out tasks more closely
for example a report can be generated
and provided to an auditor for
compliance reasons or could even be used
to estimate how long it will take to
fail an application to the opposite site
once we are satisfied with the test the
cleanup will return the environment back
to its original state
in a few moments the recovery plan can
be readjusted and run again and again
until the expected result is obtained
now that the test was successful the
recovery plan can now be run
after acknowledging the warning a
planned migration will attempt a final
sync of the data between sites whereas
the disaster recovery will start the
plan with everything in its current
state
running the plan will gracefully shut
down the virtue machines configure the
storage and power on the application in
the same prescribed order
when finished switching to site 1 shows
the virtual machines are powered off and
left off in case a rollback is needed
at site 2 the virtual machines for app 1
are now successfully running
once an admin has established that the
application is operating correctly at
the other site a reprotect can be
initiated
a reprotect uses the reverse mappings to
reconfigure the replication to flow back
in the opposite direction
acknowledging the warning and clicking
finish the reprotect is started
in a short amount of time the process
completes and returns to the recovery
plan
now that the application is running at
site 2 the placeholder vms are now shown
in the inventory at site 1.
this indicates that the application is
now ready to be gracefully migrated or
failed back to site 1 when needed
this concludes the site recovery manager
on google cloud vmware engine video
series thank you for watching
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com vmware dash engine
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]